when some people think of a tablet being
a laptop replacement they laugh it off
because they know a tablet will never be
able to replace their laptop and for
them it could totally be true but others
just need a laptop to do basic things
like running YouTube right next to their
word document allow for easy file
transferring and get support for full
desktop browsing like you get on a PC so
for this video
we're gonna compare the new Galaxy Tab s
6 to Apple's 2018 iPad pro to see which
one is the better laptop replacement if
you've already seen our hands-on
comparison video you'll know that the
iPad pro is a step above in terms of
hardware the performance is way ahead
the display is much less reflective as
well as being much brighter it refreshes
at 120 Hertz instead of 60 the aspect
ratio is much better for browsing the
web and the stylus has much less lag
however it's priced at a higher retail
price especially if you get the full
setup with 256 gigabytes of storage the
keyboard case and the stylus but even
then the tab of 6 is better in a few
ways like being lighter having better
display quality and speaker quality as
well now let's focus on the point of
this video replacing a laptop to do that
you need a keyboard case which costs one
hundred and eighty dollars on each
tablet the iPad pros case is definitely
thinner and sleeker but the tab is sixes
case is much more feature-rich it's got
a small cover for the S Pen that is much
more secure compared to the iPad
solution the tab also gets a kickstand
that gives you incredible amounts of
adjustability compared to the iPads
option of just two angles and if you
want to use it in tablet mode the tabs
keyboard comes off separately unlike the
iPad pro where you either have to fold
the keyboard over and deal with feeling
the keys under your fingers or take the
case off completely the keys on the tab
feel really good with great key travel
thanks to it being thicker but all the
keys are scrunched together and the
number keys are offset to the left side
compared to a traditional keyboard which
causes miss types all the time until you
finally get used to it the layout on the
ipad pro's keyboard case however is
great now that tab s6 is keyboard case
has something very special an actual
trackpad is
definitely not the best track that out
there because it's pretty small and it
tends to trigger a right-click instead
of a left-click if you're not used to it
which was really annoying but it's still
a trackpad and with it comes traditional
cursor support which actually works both
in and outside of Samsung decks which
I'll talk about in just a minute the
iPad does have Mouse support just like
the tab but you don't get a cursor you
get this little circle thing that simply
imitates swipes and taps so it's not
really that useful iPad OS was just
released for the iPad which gives you
new multitasking features in full
desktop mode in Safari with traditional
keyboard shortcuts but it's really
lacking some of the fundamental laptop
like features we're really happy that
you can finally connect USB flash drives
and other storage drives but in my
opinion Samsung does it better and they
do it with Dex
simply press the Dex shortcut on the
keyboard and it turns on within moments
all the same apps you had open stay open
and you have a traditional taskbar with
literally all the information you need
you can easily adjust the volume change
your Wi-Fi settings view minimized apps
take screenshots view notifications and
get a full traditional view of all of
your apps all at once you can easily
open two file windows and drag and drop
files just like on a PC this is true
file management not like the iPads
lackluster files app you get much better
multitasking than on the iPad pro with
resizable windows that you can minimize
into the taskbar or maximized to fill up
the entire screen all in all the iPad
feels really limited when it's next to
the tab s6 with Dex the trackpad on the
tab isn't great and it takes some time
to get used to but at least you can hook
up a bluetooth mouse and get an actual
cursor unlike the iPad and for a few
minutes while filming view roll I
actually forgot that I was using a
tablet when I was using Dex on the tab
s6 now it might sound like I'm dissing
on the iPad but this video is focused
solely on laptop replace ability in
terms of being a tablet the iPad pro
absolutely destroys the tap s6 the
performance is much better the 120 Hertz
display refresh rate is amazing and by
the way the Apple pencil is better than
the s-pen in every single way just look
at how much lag the s-pen
as compared to the pencil this is a
difference you'll actually feel every
day if you're a stylus user and the S
Pen doesn't get the same third-party app
support like the Apple pencil so when
some apps like Lightroom the button on
the side does absolutely nothing and if
you look at app support in general the
tab at 6 doesn't support a lot of the
best apps like luma fusion good notes
notability procreate an affinity photo
that's the biggest downfall of the tab
s6 since some developers don't think
it's worth bringing their high-end apps
to Android and right now you can get the
2018 iPad pro for only twenty four
dollars more than the tab s6 it comes
with less storage and doesn't include
the Apple pencil but it still makes you
think twice about getting the tab s6 for
$650 so for high-end users who need the
best apps and performance the iPad pro
is irreplaceable but for regular users
who need a basic laptop for basic stuff
the tab is six is honestly a much better
laptop replacement the iPad pro is great
especially with iPad OS but in terms of
being a laptop replacement it's really
lacking cursor support with customizable
windows and the ability to have a
traditional taskbar that's what's so
great about decks and the iPad gets
nothing close to it of course the tab s6
is far from perfect with the trackpad
that doesn't really work that well and
an oddly laid out keyboard but when you
use it with decks it actually feels like
a laptop if you enjoyed this video
please click that button above to
subscribe for our iPhone 11 pro and
Apple watch series 5 videos coming this
weekend thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]